- Batman on Batman
justice lamp Shazam that happened I mean
we got it there was a bunch of stories
that ran I think on Thursday Friday
Thursday my thing
we had a Annabel creation on the boat
the director that is David Sandberg and
like right before the interview with
them like somebody was like I hear he
might be making Shazam one day another
god I'd be [ __ ] funny so i ordering
the interview i go hey witch what do you
what's down the road for you man like
you can jump into the world of crazy
superheroes or something like that and
he goes at my next movie of Shazam like
with no irony whatsoever no build-up no
showmanship like get ready for this
Batman
get ready it's good shows I'm or
something like that literally just like
and I was like are you [ __ ] serious
he goes yes yes I am serious I was like
what you're just gonna say it like that
like I thought you danced around it I
had no idea just so I said how'd you get
that you know suddenly I was falling
down a different rabbit hole people
seemed so happy to be in the DC Universe
big bad way man
Shazam um what do you think I can't call
him Captain Marvel that's his real name
right you never call him got Marvel in
the movie I mean they should just
[ __ ] make the blackout a movie and
move on cuz that's all anybody really
wants is the rock as black Adam and I
think I saw something on Twitter I don't
know if it's confirmed but Jeff that
said Jeff John says that that the rock
is not going to be in the Shazam movie
again we can look it up and see it but
that's what I read earlier today because
I - mom - they said Shazam I think he
has an interview it's like all mine the
rock is blowing and it's not like the
director was like haha you didn't really
say anything so maybe they're like Jeff
is you know going hey before everyone
gets excited we're making Shazam not
black Adam but you're absolutely right
everyone wants us yeah so Justice League
dark apparently they're still trying to
make why not just look instead of
waiting what why have you got a black
Adam why can't he be [ __ ] cat Marvel
I can t be Shazam he could be I mean
[ __ ] I'd do it make him she said I
wouldn't be she said no you don't I was
like nobody wants nobody wants had a I'm
a middle-aged man I love comic books and
then I'm a little white kid this is
weird
that'd be an interesting movie what
about ya the Wizards give a little white
kid power to turn into you you want to
also not be able to catch a cab
come on kid gimme that you can solve
that problem I can't catch a cab Shazam
and you a little white kid and happy and
they polled I know money is a little way
dude
oh [ __ ] you're right well when they stop
and [ __ ] and you're like Shazam and you
jump in town real quick like tiny and
privilege giant and target that's the
way you down forces a movie how do you
feel as the compactors I did see some
people on Twitter grousing about you
know come on man if it aint captain if
you can't call a cat Marvel in Captain
Marvel they can't call Captain Marvel
because Marvel has a character called
Captain Marvel who showed up today we'll
get to that in a minute
but uh but you can't do the DC movie
under the proper term I feel like
they're giving us DC movies just to give
us DC movies I think I'm I don't give us
I love taken but like it she's like I
think they're giving us [ __ ] just to
give us [ __ ] like I will take all the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]